[Música]
nunca se preguntaron por qué los
economistas y los meteorólogos siempre
se equivocan en sus predicciones o al
menos casi siempre es que los chicos del
tiempo son personas perversas que les
gusta vernos mojados o los economistas
crean crisis financieras a propósito
hubo un economista llamado para carlos
onganía que se hizo la misma pregunta en
el año 2008 realizó una investigación
sobre las predicciones de diferentes
tipos de instituciones públicas y
privadas estudio las predicciones de
gobiernos ministerios universidades
periodistas y su conclusión fue tajante
se dio cuenta que el 90% de estas
predicciones eran erróneas dicho de otra
forma que si los médicos se equivocarán
tanto como los economistas estaríamos
todos muertos pero si podemos predecir
con una precisión de segundos cuándo
será el próximo eclipse porque no
podemos saber cuál va a ser el precio de
la zanahoria en un mes
esta es por la teoría del caos también
conocida como teoría de los sistemas
dinámicos complejos pero creo que vende
más hablar de caos verdad
edward lawrence funda de los pioneros en
este campo de la ciencia y él sostenía
que el aleteo de las alas de una
mariposa en brasil podría provocar un
tornado en texas esto es lo que se
conoce como el efecto mariposa
él era meteorólogo y en la década de los
están intentando predecir el clima
con la ayuda de las computadoras de
aquella época realizó diferentes
experimentos uno de ellos para que el
poder del procesamiento de las
computadoras sea más rápido decía
empezando por la mitad y redondeando
únicamente a tres decimales al cabo de
un tiempo volvió a chequear los
resultados y se dio cuenta que éstos no
tenían nada que ver con los que había
realizado en su primera predicción y no
sólo eso sino que conforme más alejado
en el tiempo más distintos eran aún se
dio cuenta que no podía predecir los
comportamientos de sistemas que están
compuestos por una enorme cantidad de
elementos que estos elementos al mismo
tiempo se interrelaciona entre sí y como
si fuera poco puede ser que más de un
sistema se superponga al mismo tiempo
por ejemplo el clima depende desde la
presión atmosférica la temperatura y las
corrientes marinas las montañas hasta de
la posición de la tierra respecto al sol
y para que les quede un poco más claro
les voy a contar una historia viví un
año en india y mi pasatiempo favoritos
era observar el tránsito
vivía en un décimo piso y pasaba horas
mirando hacia la esquina de mi casa
donde confluyen dos calles con tránsito
constante pero fluido y cuando hablamos
de tránsito en la india se podrá
imaginar hablamos de cientos de motos
risas tux peatones autos conduciendo a
manny contramano por igual y como si eso
fuera poco también participaban ellas
las reinas de la calle las 'vacas
sagradas' bueno y al cabo de un tiempo
yo decidí comprar una motito y
participar en ese caos y allí me di
cuenta cómo funcionaba primero vamos
todos a una velocidad razonable si
íbamos tomando decisiones constantemente
en relación a las decisiones que toman
las demás personas por ejemplo si una
vaca se cruza por acá quien va delante
mío va a decir doblar para la derecha
yo voy a doblar para la izquierda y
estas decisiones que estamos tomando van
a afectar a todas las decisiones que va
a tomar quienes vienen detrás nuestro de
esta forma va fluyendo un orden
espontáneo
resulta ser mucho más fluido que el
tránsito de muchas de las grandes
ciudades llenos de señales oficiales de
tránsito o semáforos y lo que más me
fascinaba de todo esto era cómo
funcionaba sin que nadie lo dirija
arriba hacia abajo sino que funcionaba
se iba organizando de abajo hacia arriba
y a esta altura se estarán preguntando
bueno y qué tiene que ver todo esto con
la economía y para eso vamos a intentar
llevar todo este conocimiento al campo
de esta ciencia y les voy a hacer una
pregunta cuál es una de las principales
preocupaciones de los argentinos
cuál es el precio del dólar exacto
pasamos horas discutiendo que si está
muy alto que si está muy bajo que si
debería valer cinco pesos más que cinco
pesos menos que cuánto y la verdad es
que no hay forma científica de
determinar el precio de ningún bien en
la sociedad porque el mercado adivinaron
es otro sistema caótico y este sistema
está compuesto por las 16 que millones
de nosotros tomamos desde el momento en
que nos despertamos hasta que nos vamos
a dormir
tendemos a antropomórficas al mercado es
decir a darle cualidades de ser humano
de carne y hueso entonces decimos que el
mercado piensa el mercado ofrece el
mercado demanda castiga pero la verdad
es que el mercado no puede realizar
ninguna de esas ninguna de esas acciones
ya que no tiene existencia real más allá
de los individuos que la componen
quienes sí podemos pensar demandar
ofrecer o castigar somos nosotros las
personas entonces qué es el mercado
bueno el mercado es un proceso es un
proceso de descubrimiento constante
donde cada uno de nosotros va tomando
decisiones sobre cuáles son los fines
que queremos alcanzar y cuáles son los
medios más idóneos que creemos que vamos
a lograr aquellos fines y este proceso
sea gracias a la comunicación y
cooperación entre cientos de extraños
todos los días cada uno de ellos
impredecible en sí mismo pero no es sólo
en argentina que no podemos predecir el
futuro en economía
no somos tan
el uso de modelos matemáticos para
predecir el futuro en la economía está
tan naturalizado que pareciera que es la
única forma correcta de abordar esta
ciencia
alan greenspan el ex presidente de la
reserva federal que sería como el banco
central de los eeuu no podía comprender
cómo sus modelos matemáticos siendo los
más caros y complejos del mundo no
pudieron predecir la crisis financiera
del 2008 la falla de estos modelos se da
justamente por la teoría del caos y
encima tiene un agravante que tiene que
ver con las características de la
información necesarias para que esas
predicciones sean correctas esa
información está dispersa en la cabecita
de cada uno de nosotros y la vamos
creando a medida que vamos actuando y
como si eso fuera poco para
complejizaron más las cosas esa es una
información tácita es una información
subjetiva es decir que la formamos desde
nuestro estrecho punto de vista dicho de
otra forma no podemos de ninguna manera
todo este volumen de información hacia
una computadora y mucho menos que esa
computadora realice predicciones
certeras sobre cuáles van a ser nuestros
gustos preferencias o decisiones que
vamos a tomar en el futuro no hay
ninguna persona en el mundo entero que
tenga todo el conocimiento necesario
para fabricar este aparentemente simple
lápiz de madera
para fabricar este lápiz se necesita
madera la madera proviene de un árbol
que alguien en algún momento plantó una
semilla lo regó los fertilizó llegado el
momento cortaron ese árbol para cortar
el árbol se necesitaron hay dibujar un
hacha probablemente haya sido con una
sierra para fabricar las sierras se
necesitaron metales así como el metal de
este castillo o el grafito que usamos
para escribir que proviene de alguna
mina luego todas estas materias primas
fueron transportadas
para ello se destaron barcos camiones
trenes para que funcione de estos medio
de transporte se está petróleo se
necesita combustible si tuviéramos que
hablar sobre todo el proceso de
extracción y refinación del petróleo
necesitaríamos una charla tel entera
únicamente para eso
esta goma probablemente venga de malasia
de donde el árbol del caucho ni siquiera
es nativo fue llevado a iu por unos
comerciantes que descubrieron que
crecían muy bien en su está asiático la
pintura y el pegamento que mantiene las
dos partes del lápiz juntas no tengo ni
la menor idea de dónde vienen
y fíjense qué detalle más interesante la
cantidad de personas que cooperaron cada
una aportando su pequeño granito de
arena cada uno aportando su pequeña
porción del conocimiento para que
nosotros podamos disfrutar de este
-insisto aparentemente simple lápiz de
madera y así como el tránsito en india
todo este proceso productivo todo este
orden espontáneo del mercado no hubo
nadie que lo dirigía de arriba hacia
abajo sino que se iba dirigiendo de
abajo hacia arriba de forma espontánea y
evolutiva resumiendo son todas estas las
características las que hace imposible
determinar cuál es el precio de un kilo
de morrón una acción una tasa de interés
o la cotización del dólar
desconfíen de cualquier persona que les
diga el precio de tal bien debería ser
éste desconfíen porque esa persona sin
importar cuán buena
o bien intencionada este terminará
cayendo en el peor de los pecados
intelectuales del ser humano el pecado
de la fatal arrogancia me gustaría
cerrar con una frase del economista y
jurista austríaco premio nobel de
economía
fredrik con hayek que sostiene que la
curiosa tarea de la ciencia económica es
demostrar al hombre lo poco que saben
sobre aquello que creen que pueden
diseñar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]